- Big news outta the Supreme Court!
There is nothing standing in the way
of New York prosecutors getting
former President Donald Trump's taxes
for purposes of a criminal investigation.
Recently the Supreme Court
denied a stay request from Trump.
Basically, this is the whole game,
it's not about a decision on the merits.
The Trump camp wanted to prevent
the New York prosecutors
from getting his taxes
while the Supreme Court
was figuring all this out.
And the Supreme court says,
"No, we will not stay things,
things will go forward,"
and now the New York
prosecutors should be able
to get access to former
President Trump's taxes.
And that's a big deal because Mazers,
the accounting firm that
was holding these records,
has wanted to comply with prosecutors,
so there's nothing that stops them
from handing those over to
the prosecutors immediately.
And that's continual bad
news for the Trump camp
because New York prosecutors
just signed up Mark Pomerantz,
who is a former federal prosecutor
who appears to be an expert in these kind
of white collar tax-related crimes.
So let's see what happens.
And if you were a member
of the Trump organization,
I may actually see you in court.